it's estimated more than 26 million
people around the world have dug into
their family histories with the help of
at-home DNA kits but finding your
ancestors often requires much more than
just submitting your DNA in this growing
field of ancestry amateurs we discovered
an unlikely Pro and he's only 18 years
old CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Michelle Miller met up with this
genealogy whiz Michelle who is he and
how does he do it
and he just turned 18 his name is Erik
Schubert and for him DNA results are
often just his first clue he also spends
hours a day digging through public
records to find answers for its clients
we've been following Schubert for months
now asking him to shoot video diaries of
his process and you'll see the results
are nothing less than life-changing
let's just see if you tell me nothing
let's see what happens to watch Erik
Schubert on the hunt say your dad's
ross-miller doctor is to watch someone
who's found his groove here's a world
record the New Jersey teen has become
something of a genealogy expert she's
born in Daytona Beach June 2nd 1893 Wow
in just over five minutes he used Google
public records census data and newspaper
clippings to track my family back to the
19th century
your great grandfather so this is 1817
in Georgia how hard is this to do
anybody can do it it just takes a lot of
practice at around 10 years old Schubert
started digging into his own family's
past as a cure for boredom now at 18 he
estimates he's helped more than a
thousand people find their roots
two big puzzles like you just have to
look at all the pieces and put together
he often takes just days to find the
answers his clients have been searching
for for decades both parents and the
twin thing is correct
really Eric it's been like 24 hours
where do you start
uh uh it honestly depends like if
someone's adopted they can't find their
parents names but big
non-identifying info from the state your
mother was 26 she was a homemaker
your father was an auto mechanic he was
26 and to some people it looks like
nothing but to me with paired with the
DNA results it's easiest by what may be
PI for Schubert is deeply meaningful to
the people he helps like Kate de santis
I've gone through my life not looking
like anyone you know and to see a
picture of my birth mother and then to
find out I have siblings and I look like
I belong and it was overwhelming for
Schubert this side job requires hours a
day pursuing a dozen cases while
juggling his full-time job high school
sounds to me like he really pours
himself into it as a mom does that it
all worried you yes because I also want
him to enjoy life Schubert has worked
with people all over the country but he
found perhaps his most fulfilling case
much closer to home like I've known you
for so long like how did I not know you
were adopted about a year ago he helped
his friend Sammy Lynam find her
biological mother but her mom wanted no
contact it hurts that she doesn't want
to get to know me but like I respect
that it's her decision and I can only do
so much - are you really okay with that
I don't know then she got the courage to
dig into her dad's side she's one mom
who we it's a business card with the
name who we think has to be her father
the picture of the person I'm looking
for somewhere the Internet
30 minutes later he found Linings dad
and more hi Jasmine my name is Sammy and
I'm reaching out because I think we are
half-siblings our camera was there the
first time Lynam met her half-sister
Jasmine Underhill
when you saw each other's faces you saw
each other live yeah so cool we kind of
Li clicked right away yeah yeah Lynam is
also going to be a not for the first
time Underhill is having a baby I just
remember the texts like Sammy saying
like oh my god like I'm gonna be a name
it's that excitement the potential for a
happy ending that drives Schubert every
time so I'm gonna call this case closed
[Laughter]
next week he plans to head to
Elizabethtown College has fallen while
he says it was trying to focus on his
schoolwork
he knows his passion for genealogy will
creep in and Sammy
she is eagerly awaiting the birth of her
nephew which is due oh that's so great
July it's it's fascinating watching him
him work I know lightning-quick
did you see that found my family yes and
I look at all these people that dedicate
you know businesses to helping you
attract it you know is that
lickety-split on company there's such a
huge thirst for people to know more
about their history and their own life
story it's a very powerful stuff right
and he only sometimes sometimes charges
people and that's but when he really
digs in and it takes much longer and I
like to friend and client next is yeah I
hope Sammy's telomers Ron I'll just say
that